have fbi agents found what they were
looking for in donald trump's home the
former u.s president says the search of
his florida residents is part of a plan
to destroy him but what does this mean
for his potential second run for the
white house
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
mohammad jim zhum fbi agents in the u.s
state of florida have conducted a
criminal search of former president
donald trump's home it's seen as a
significant escalation of the federal
investigation into whether trump
illegally removed classified documents
from the white house as he was leaving
office in january last year trump
criticized the fbi search calling it a
weaponization of the justice system
we'll bring in our guests shortly but
first this report from jillian wolfe
the fbi's search of donald trump's
mar-a-lago estate on monday marked a
dramatic escalation
the former u.s president is facing a
number of allegations into his conduct
in the waning days of his administration
for much of the year there had been
small cracks in trump's political
support but a day after the fbi's
unprecedented search republicans rallied
behind the former leader when all this
went down in mar-a-lago my phone blew up
friends and family members asked me what
in the world is going on
why is the law not being applied equally
you know friends texted me things like
is the fbi turned into the gestapo
the search was part of the u.s justice
department's investigation into
allegations trump removed classified
documents from the white house
the u.s agency in charge of collecting
and storing presidential documents had
notified the justice department about
the discovery of at least 15 boxes of
white house documents at trump's
mar-a-lago home it said some of those
records were classified
the house committee investigating the
january sixth attack on the u.s capitol
had also heard evidence about the
removal of classified documents when
trump left office along with allegations
trump had repeatedly shredded or
disposed of classified material after
reading it as president
republicans in congress are calling the
search a political witch hunt initiating
an investigation into the allegations of
the fbi we now find that justice in
america is not equal
it's determined upon whether you want to
go after a political a person or not and
you go after your political foes i think
that's wrong
democrats say the fbi action shows no
one is above the law
and the white house says president joe
biden was not given advance notice about
the search the president and the white
house learned about this fbi search from
public reports we learned just like the
american public did and we did not have
advance notice
of this activity
president biden has been very clear from
before he was elected president and
throughout his time in office that the
justice department conducts its
investigations independently he believes
in the rule of law
donald trump remains the republican
party's most influential voice and has
been considering the idea running again
his ability to tap into the frustrations
of conservative voters has helped him
overcome two impeachments and the
fallout from the january 6 attack
his allies say the fbi search of his
florida home could strengthen his
standing once again
for inside story julian wolfe
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests in rest in virginia rina shop
founder and principal of relax
strategies she's also a conservative
political advisor
in washington d.c henry olsen a senior
fellow at the ethics and public policy
center and columnist for the washington
post he's also the author of the
working-class republican ronald reagan
and the return of the blue-collar
conservatism
and in london julie norman associate
professor at university college london
and co-director of the ucl center on u.s
politics a warm welcome to you all and
thanks so much for joining us today on
inside story julie let me start with you
today and let's talk for a moment about
the significance of all of this first of
all is this unprecedented
has a search warrant ever been executed
at the home of a former u.s president
before and you know what kind of
evidence would have been needed in order
to convince a judge to sign off
on a search warrant like this
sure so as is widely known by now this
is unprecedented justice has
investigated presidents before but i
never to the extent of a search warrant
for a former president so as you noted
this would have had to have gotten
approval from a federal magistrate judge
as it did in order to get a warrant
though it's just probable cause that a
crime was committed so it doesn't
necessarily mean there's firm evidence
it doesn't necessarily mean there's
going to be a criminal proceeding it
just means that it's warrant for a
search it should be noted a search
warrant is rare in this kind of
investigation this is an investigation
around classified documents
usually these are resolved through
negotiations maybe a subpoena but a
search really is unusual so the question
of course is still unknown at least to
the public of what the fbi was looking
for
if they found it and what the
implications will be and we certainly
don't know that just yet
rina there has been polling done
recently showing that a majority of
republicans did not want mr trump to be
the party's nominee in 2024 before the
news of this search at mar-a-lago was
there a sense that republican lawmakers
may have been ready to move on from mr
trump
and has the fact that this search has
happened has that upended all of that
now
well in the past few months i've
definitely heard uh a greater sense than
in a very long time that the country may
you know really be looking for something
fresh something new uh but again it's
almost as if uh we don't know where the
pendulum is swung entirely
for republicans that i speak to there
are a great many who are still very
committed to the make america great
again movement who feel that trump maybe
should be given a second look but
there's also a fair amount whether
you're talking about the mid-atlantic
region of republicans or western
republicans or even southern republicans
there are a fair amount that want to try
something new perhaps in the form of
florida governor ron desantis it's hard
to tell what will happen now as of
course we know in this era the court of
public opinion feels to be the only
court that matters so the political
ramifications particularly in this
republican party i think will be quite
severe will they rally behind trump and
stay there um what will the midterms do
are is there going to be a new energy
behind trump endorsed candidates who
were losing for many weeks and and then
now we see sort of a resurgence of some
these are all open-ended questions right
now because this is such an obviously
unprecedented move um it because no
former president has done anything that
has warranted such a search that's what
i like to remind republicans is that
this has never been warranted so let's
be sort of cautious in the moment about
what this really means about the future
of the gop
henry uh based on first impressions from
your vantage point does this help or
hurt trump
it marginally helps trump within the
republican party because there's a large
number of people who like him maybe
considering moving on but now he seems
to be in the targets of the of the air
quotes real enemy the democrats in the
left so in the
short term this is something that's
going to slightly increase trump's
standing within the republican party but
it's still a long way to go and we don't
know what's going to come out i don't
think this will have lasting impulse but
certainly it gives trump a brief bit of
momentum that he lacked prior to the
raid
julie if the fbi doesn't find anything
if nothing from this search sticks to
trump what's the blowback going to be
and how much would that benefit
trump if nothing comes out of this i
think it will benefit trump massively uh
you know trump has really embraced a
narrative throughout
his uh his time in office and afterwards
of persecution of grievance of you know
being under a witch hunt with the
federal government in general but
especially with justice and so
this incident plays very much into that
narrative gives him a specific instant
and specific optics to point to and it's
one that we've already seen resonating
very strongly with many of his
supporters you know people coming out in
mar-a-lago on monday night already
rallying around trump and it just puts
him back in the center of the narrative
in exactly the place he wants to be and
i could see him leveraging this
definitely in the short term and really
well into a campaign if he so wished
henry how strong is trump's grip on the
republican party still um and and what
is his record thus far when it comes to
the candidates that he's been supporting
during the primaries
he's actually uh turned around his
endorsement record he was looking like
he was losing a fair number of them
earlier in the primary but he's had a
very good winning streak recently
winning most of his contested
endorsements you know i think the fair
statement right now is that trump is has
the upper hand in the republican party
but that there is a substantial number
of republicans who may want to go along
with many of trump-like policies but do
not want to endorse full-throated
trump-ism or bet behind trump's
candidates we saw in the wisconsin
primary just last night that the
incumbent lieutenant governor lost to a
trump back candidate but got 42 percent
same thing in arizona where an opponent
to trump's endorsed candidate got close
to 45
so let's say the party is divided uh
with trump's supporters having the upper
hand uh and that means that there's
still an opening for someone to come
through and challenge him but it's still
clear that trump has that slight upper
edge within gop and henry you talked
about the the party being divided but
but let me ask you i mean just how
fractured is the republican party right
now
against the democrats it's not very
fractured the republican factions may
disagree with one another on how far or
how fast to move but against the
democrats i think you'll see a lot of
unity
but there's going to be a real question
whether trump is somebody who can and
should lead the ticket and that's one
that's going to come to a head after the
midterm elections
rina you know top congressional
republicans have been rushing to defend
mr trump after uh the news broke that
that that search warrant was executed is
this in any way surprising to you i want
to talk for a moment about the fact that
you know you have former u.s vice
president mike pence he's called on u.s
attorney general merrick garland to give
a full accounting to the public of why
the search warrant was carried out at
mar-a-lago uh you know of course mike
pence it's it's known that that he is
somebody who was in hiding uh when when
that invasion of the capital happened on
january 6 that you had trump supporters
who wanted to harm him so the fact that
you know he has come out and put out
this statement at a time when there was
a lot of speculation that that pence
might run in 2024 and the fact that
there are these republican leaders who
privately may be saying they don't
support trump are now publicly defending
him does that surprise you
it is a bit surprising even after many
years of trump in office to watch
establishment republicans those sitting
in congress right now who are elected
members of congress elected to a branch
that is supposed to check the other
branch be a check on their power um
completely surround the former president
with uh continued adoration and love and
defense of what is sort of
his his way of going about things his
unique style
of continuing to engage in uh
hypocritical action and and talk uh but
the what aboutism as well it almost
feels uh as if we've entered this new
era of politics that we cannot walk back
from we had many weeks of the january 6
select committee within the house uh
tell us uh that there was
well-documented evidence of trump and
and really his egregious actions to try
to remain in power to grab power that
was not constitutionally his uh but
still
even despite that this republican party
does not have to embrace him and they
continue to so it shows sort of the
level of pettiness of some of these
elected members of congress it they may
be defending themselves they may be
protecting themselves they know that
money is still tied to the make america
great again based so it's it it almost
leaves anyone who's even a political
insider scratching their heads about at
what point does the divorce happen
between establishment republicans and
the trump sort of empire that continues
to pervade the republican party that
again is another open-ended question
this is just a time where it's just too
quick it's too early to tell we have to
get past these midterms to know more
about what the american electorate
really thinks of trump and will he be
the standard bearer in 2024. well reena
speaking of the midterms you know it had
been reported
that up until the news broke that this
search warrant was executed that many
republicans had been privately urging
donald trump not to announce that he was
going to run in 2024 because they
thought that might be damaging in the
midterm elections for other candidates
now it seems that there are republicans
that are calling on trump to actually
announce before the midterms because
they believe that will help the party
do you think that this means that donald
trump will officially enter the
presidential race soon
well if i help the party you mean that a
former president who again was sort of
the the standard bearer not just sort of
he was the elected former president uh
you know if by helping him that means he
doesn't go to jail which would just be
my goodness uh absolutely a shock to
this system to the entire country but no
one can be above the law in these united
states i think the actions uh that we've
seen in the past 36 hours
uh particularly tell us that democracy
in action is an action here in the
united states it's in motion and it's
working and we're not a banana republic
because even if you are now a private
citizen who held the highest office in
the land you are subject to the law and
so we have one side of the story right
now that is trump's version we have yet
to hear why this legal search was
conducted on his private property in
florida we will learn more in the coming
days that will tell us exactly what this
means for a former president has he
broken a part of our us code that
prohibits him from
holding office again this is all very
consequential in so many ways it all
hangs on the balance for the future of
the republican party do people want to
defend trump at all costs or are they
willing to say let him go like the rnc
committee chairwoman herself just
alluded to i believe it was just last
week and if not it was a few days prior
to that
where she said that they would not even
pay trump's legal bills anymore uh if he
were to continue on this path of a
potential candidacy so we are again
hanging in the balance as uh myself a
former republican strategist and and a
long-time registered republican but
somebody who wishes to see a healthy
republican party exist
julie democrats are fresh off of some
big legislative wins right now the fact
that the focus has now shifted to trump
does that hurt the democrats going into
the midterms
well as you said this week was probably
not the week that biden and the white
house wanted a story like this
necessarily you know coming off the
climate bill win chips some other very
long weighted legislation finally coming
through and of course trump has just
completely flipped the news cycle uh
with the with what's happening this week
so from the democratic point of view uh
you they would like more emphasis on
those pieces but at the same time you
know many democrats uh have been keen to
see some legal movement from any of the
number investigations that trump is
currently uh under
he's expected also to testify today in a
separate investigation in new york so
many democrats have been looking for a
justice to come down a bit stronger on
trump as we have said though you know i
think if there is not anything to show
from this
that will blow back on democrats at the
end of the day and many who are maybe
celebrating right now
are maybe not thinking about some of the
repercussions of this in terms of the
campaign and the electorate and how this
might galvanize trump uh and and julie
if we're talking about uh galvanizing
trump supporters you know it's being
reported that there is some violent
rhetoric uh that's been appearing on
pro-trump online forums is there a lot
of concern out there that that this
could all lead to violence at some point
well there certainly is concern and ever
since obviously january 6 i think people
are taking this kind of rhetoric more
seriously than they may have in the past
a lot of
terms and phrases that were being uh you
know put on social media on twitter
since the news of the search came out
certainly have very aggressive you know
very very violence leaning connotations
to them
with that said i think we should always
kind of be cautious about not not
jumping to kind of alarmist conclusions
with this um you know people are going
to react to this there are going to be
protests but right now we have not seen
uh you know any kind of uh extreme
expression of violence and reaction to
this again trump himself i think will
have a lot of sway in how much that side
of the rhetoric builds or not he's
obviously encouraged it in the past
and we can only hope that this
de-escalates rather than escalates in
terms of the violent rhetoric around it
henry do you think that as a result of
any of these investigations that it
might be possible that mr trump could be
barred from running again for president
you know i don't think that there is a
legal way to bar him from running for
president short of jailing him
that uh there's a lot of belief that you
cannot add to the constitutional
requirements for running for office and
there are no constitutional requirements
saying that somebody under indictment or
somebody under suspicion or somebody
who's been convicted even cannot run for
the presidency so i think short of
securing conviction that's upheld on
appeal that has in behind bars
i don't think there's any way that this
is going to prevent him from running for
office convicting him in the impeachment
trial would have been the way to do that
rina
we've heard from house minority leader
kevin mccarthy um he told attorney
general merrick garland to preserve your
documents and clear your calendar
and he warned that there would be a
probe into all of this when republicans
take back the house in the midterm
elections now if republicans do regain
control of the house of representatives
come november uh are we going to see
republicans launch a lot of retaliatory
investigations and and what's that going
to do
the country is already so polarized the
political parties are already so
polarized what kind of effect would that
have
well republicans have been calling um
you know making calls about this january
6th select committee in the house that
that did these public hearings for these
past many weeks uh they've been saying
that that is a sort of one-sided uh sort
of
investigation that that is purely
political and a witch hunt and it is
happening through the u.s house of
representatives because of nancy pelosi
the speaker so so they've already sort
of taken to that line of messaging and
and been rather successful with their
base uh plotting with that they've
fundraised off of it uh massive amounts
they continue to beat that steady drum
of the democrats are trying to ruin the
way uh your your way of life uh they're
trying to
you know do things that will will affect
your bottom line lately this entire week
uh the the messaging point has been that
the irs is expanding they're coming for
you they're hiring upward uh close to 90
000 new agents and they're coming for
you the little guy because you're a
conservative so so do not be surprised
if you you hear this from congressional
republicans of course the leader uh
mccarthy is is giving away his entire
playbook he wants to exact revenge on
democrats and he's gonna start it from
the top down if house republicans take
over this fall that will be the first
thing they do is hold these kind of
hearings because they will say democrats
already did the very same thing
um henry you know this certainly is not
the first time that former president
trump has been accused of mishandling
classified materials we do know that in
the u.s the president has the authority
to declassify any information if it is
determined ultimately that mr trump took
classified material that he that he
shouldn't have that he's uh held on to
it uh couldn't mr trump just claim to
have declassified it would would that be
enough to end all of this
i think that's a process through which
you have to go to declassify it and of
course one can only do that as the
president the question is whether he
did that while he was serving in office
i don't think it's something that he can
wave a wand after the fact and say these
documents are all okay if he didn't go
through the procedures that establishes
declassification prior to his departure
from office then i don't think he's
going to be able to make that claim
julie i saw you nodding along to what
henry was saying did you want to jump in
well just to to agree with that right
that uh you know while in office the
president can can declassify but
afterwards they cannot and so it's
unclear what the status of those
documents uh would be and you know it's
important to know back in the spring uh
with kind of the first uh boxes that
were were taken from mar-a-lago or were
uh were given from mar-a-lago um you
know there were classified documents in
there so we already we know that trump
has had some classified materials but
again um there's that can usually be
assuaged through different kinds of
negotiations and the the worry here is
that there's something much more
sensitive or uh much more pertinent to
some of the other legal challenges going
on but um but i would agree it's
complicated because of that presidential
uh power to declassify if you will and
julie from your vantage point uh you
know from what you're seeing and reading
and hearing um does it look to you like
trump may be in in
real serious legal peril here
uh you know i really think it's too
early to say we just don't have enough
information about what was found and
what it's going to mean
i would again emphasize that in order to
bar trump from running from office again
that would still be a very long way off
i think a criminal proceeding just
around having classified documents would
be unlikely and would probably be seen
as an overreach if those documents
actually related to something very
serious then i could see an actual
proceeding uh moving forward potentially
but again i think trump will continue to
uh to leverage this as much as possible
through an appeals process etc and and
really it will be very difficult legally
to keep him from running again reno we
only have about a minute left i'm going
to ask you the same question from your
vantage point do you think the trump is
in real legal trouble here
well it depends uh you know really how
this whole thing plays out because there
is a presidential records act and if and
if this legal search was fully about
classified documents and how they were
handled by trump and really what the fbi
knows at this point then it becomes a
question of who's going to enforce a
presidential records act for the first
time uh there were there was a former
chief of staff there were other top
advisers who warned president trump
while he was in the white house about
that act and his handling of information
uh but it still to this day nobody has
really been punished for violating that
act are we going to be a country that
holds accountable our former elected
leaders that is the question that i'm
willing i'm ready and waiting for an
answer for all right well we have run
out of time so we're going to have to
leave the conversation there today
thanks so much to all of our guests rina
shaw henry olsen and julie norman
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website al jazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim jerome and the whole team
here bye for now
[Music]
you